so this is alone together uh first of
all the way I like how the few that I
missed all of a sudden like real shit
yeah I was gonna say he's caught up Oh
everyone was like no God has to watch it
yeah I said he would watch it don't
worry so he's all caught up he's in
episode uh this is one of the few I
think I saw like maybe three or four
episodes like before I start watching
the show just randomly on Cartoon
Network and this is one that I saw and
this is one of the episodes that made me
say this is fascinating like I gotta
watch this show like this is this is a
fucking intriguing episode in my opinion
like really captured what it's like to
go to a rave and be on ecstasy I mean
it's I don't what I think of like
anything about like identity metamorphic
metamorphosis Kefka like mr berman you
know like serve all this really add just
social anxiety no like this is just
doing so fucking much in my opinion and
you know take kid show out of it just
any show I mean it's like this is just a
fascinating episode it's I think we'll
see you know but it's the one where
Stephen fuses with Connie and you know
which they say Ken Kenny fuse with a
human who knows and can end it yes and
now he she I think it's a she and
Mammalia she but whatever um you know
our know she she's Asian
mrs. Doubtfire classic um but yeah
there's so this other fuse together and
it's it's just they're experienced being
together and sort of what is and it
isn't quite the obvious like what you
see in comedies we're going this way no
I'm going this way on going this way no
it's like more like having severe
bipolar so yeah well it's like this
whole episode sort of takes on like a
different identity even of itself like
it's just everything sir told in a
different way so in bad fever dream not
everything is spelled out like it's not
said it's all felt this felt very much
like an episode early led by the
emotions of two people right down
dealing with it I
couldn't quite figure out half the time
who is doing the talking no but that's
what I like and that's what's so fast
thing about cuz it is like even though
this is caveny you know this is idea
that doesn't technically exist this
fusion idea you know there's a lot of
ways you can identify with this you can
identify like you know sort of infusing
with yourself fusing with another person
being in a relationship or a friendship
or a marriage or I mean any of that
stuff I mean even just identity
yeah with yourself you know it's
something where it's like I think anyone
can watch this and without it being
spelled out and spoon-fed to you you can
get a lot out of it cuz I think you can
just watch that scene and you can sort
of take whatever you want out of like
the whole second half of this episode
like during the dancing and everything I
was just in it for the doughnuts I know
I yeah pretty much I mean he pretty much
said everything I thanks sorry but yeah
I I think my favorite thing was when the
dance
according to her him harima um was not
going the way they thought it was going
to and the way the little disco ball
like surrounded them and the people like
getting old I was like man if that's not
like a perfect representation of social
anxiety I don't know what the hell is
well and even little things like when
you know but she's kind of talking to
herself or to see if it whatever the -
I'm looking at the donuts and said do
you want to stop and it starts to
separate the two donuts and things start
to go a little dark and then no and
things become normal color again it's
like little things like a fever dream
it's like one of those dreams you have
after like too much nyquil where it's
like it's not really a nightmare
nightmare but everything's a little off
I think whenever people talk about like
they'll talk about something like mm I
mean it's kind of weird comparison but
like 2001 they'll be like well it's just
a bunch of effects and that's it it's
like no there is something to like just
this different kind of state of being
and I think this episode can taps on
that I think that's a very good example
where it's like things start to go dark
when she's thinking about separating
they're like no and comes back it's like
that's not said that's not spelled out
but you can feel one I wasn't sure
what to make with the three gems
reaction they you know Pearl of course
is always concerned and then garnet was
all like really leave me into it
yeah which is funny I would have thought
that that would have been amethyst
reaction but she seemed into it to she's
such a kid hey she seemed like me yeah
but it was definitely garnet who was
like all over this yeah by the way was
when they were doing the dance lesson
what was what garnet throwing pearl up
against the wall their first like I'm
like whoa fresh like she's all even kid
she's like hey now the first time they
did it though I mean okay it's all you
know all dancing is technically sexual
as they say but it's like when they
first did the don't win was garnet and
amethyst doing the fusion like it it
seemed very sexual honestly I mean like
the moves they were doing and then I got
that out of the out of the pram no you
definitely got against the law yeah and
that gets really weird when like Stephen
Ezard gets football there's just a
little odd let's get a little yeah but
this is like I don't know there's I I
don't say was a bad thing no no no I was
just watching it like oh no like
everything what especially it officiated
substan no no but especially with this
episode and like when she goes into the
donut shop I'm just gonna say she it's
easier oh when she goes into the donut
shop
and both of them that neither both of
everyone is just sort of taken it's a
she and it so refer to shit shit their
guess um buy so when shit goes in there
completely destroys this is this but
everyone's just sort of taken back like
they don't even know they're not afraid
and they're not super happy they just
don't know how do except they're what
they're even seeing and I really like
that too
and you know way too immature I don't
know like Lars and what surveys they
they see they both seem turned on and on
I yeah but again I mean that there's
like a bajillion ways you can take that
you can take it as is what those people
then no matter what your a gender or a
sexual orientation just like you know
what they're just a track if no matter
how you slice it
no but that that is kind of a thing it's
like you know cuz again they never
specifically attentive
it's a fusion says this male or female
now and it's like so it just sort of has
this is my way to look at it it's
neither so both sides could be
attractive no I honestly I could just be
a you know what I would go gay for that
I mean yeah I don't know but it's one of
those things where it's like it you're
just kinda watching it and they're just
both sort of attracted to nor I guess if
your were gay you could be like I would
go straight for that yeah I did because
she's he she's both yeah exactly
well I met that's why I think acceptance
is like a million metaphors rapping is
really fucking is I mean I think they're
really open to interpretation because I
don't even know what exactly they're
saying no I mean this really is what
this is when I saw this episode I'm like
I gotta watch this show like this is
like just so fucking intriguing if you
like this is I mean and for kids I mean
to watch it - I get the feeling they can
watch it it's like you know if they can
watch it now and sort of get this
certain feeling from it a certain idea
and then years later when they grow up
or really any age they can watch and see
something totally different um I think
it's just a really fascinating episode
and yeah everyone seems to look at them
as just sort of drawn like they just
never seen anything like this before
this type of person they can't explain
why either and neither does the episode
the episode doesn't say why I just add
and they're drawn that way um so yeah I
really really really found this
interesting um and yeah I mean so far
it's like the one it's probably my
favorite one cuz it just felt so so new
and so different but like strangely
educational in a way - I mean it's
really kind of opening up like hey we're
in it's not all gonna be talk is not
going to be you know we're gonna explain
everything we're gonna let you feel it
well I mean garnet was right it was an
experience yes uh and and that is it -
they make the whole episode and
experience as well and you feel the
experience it's not explained it's not
talked about it's felt and I think that
is such a good thing for any type of art
to do and I thought this episode really
got that and it really really did it
well well enough about you coming back
to me
yeah the episodes I missed the the two
big ones the one with the Warped Tour
and the moment though was a lion 3 the
yeah that lion one a little rough there
I'd say that cried it's just raining in
here love us
oh good it uh the only thing that
fascinates me is when he went inside the
lion's mane there was like a treasure
chest a sword assured all this stuff
there hasn't come back for any of that
shit yeah as a kid I would be like
almost that's nice a tape was awesome
but he never brings up what the fuck was
going on with them destroying the war
portal on that green woman coming
through a jail I just realized that was
never and like that was the biggest
thing I was like I can't wait to get
some answers and then when I see they're
not I'm like oh but that was like oh
it's this episode that's right it's like
it's so fascinating that you just kind
of forget all that but ya know that was
those into a good episode good it's big
bill misty-eyed um and the Warped Tour
one was great too because it just sets
up that there's more going on out there
yeah so well the one thing I'll say to
you that I don't think I I sent the V
long I didn't bring up to you is that I
sorta have this theory maybe the three
of them are fugitives why maybe they're
the bad guy yeah when that'd be
intriguing that yeah I I don't know I
mean there's definitely something
slightly shady about the three of them's
yeah um I don't know I guess we'll find
out but yeah um the little bowling ball
things were cute um and make rushed
blown up fuck this it's dark but uh yeah
so that's pretty much my thoughts on
those in a nutshell I don't want to do
too deep this is episode 2 degree dig up
the whole thing all over again since you
already be wanted but they were they
were very good so of course it's like
the couple I miss it's just like shit
that's nothing I even missed this one
like that yeah this would be what it's
like if you're even that alright so what
happened just give me the rundown like I
don't know if I can explain it you just
don't see how I just watch just watch oh
shit
Kitt's real sister and unreal at the
same time through your mind so yeah
that's about it and we'll see you at the
next existential one later who are you
who am i who are we we are I know we're
shit yeah